Congratulations, you guys.
-Thank you.
-Four fantastic seasons.
As I told you both backstage, my
wife and I binged season four.
You nailed the landing.
But it's amazing
how you guys met.
You met on Twitter.
-Yes.
-We did.
-And it's really one of the few
nice things that I feel like
has come out of Twitter
is this wonderful show.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I think that's possibly
very true.
-Yeah, it doesn't seem like
there's any competition lately
for good things that have
happened on Twitter.
-We met when Twitter was nice,
right?
-Yeah, yeah.
And Sharon was already
an incandescent star in the U.K.
but not yet here.
And I had seen a show of hers,
because I just love
British comedy,
and I wrote her a DM,
and I said, "Listen, listen,
I like you, and I'd like
to know you in real life."
And you sent a cease and desist
letter, which I ignored,
and then we met for lunch
almost 10 years ago now.
-Yes.
-And then decided to write
a script together.
You had experience doing this.
You did not.
-Correct.
-So you really -- you really
sold her quite a bill of goods.
-I did indeed.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I had done, you know --
I'd written jokes and done
lots of stand-up
and I'd written failed pilots
and things like that.
-Books. You'd written books.
-Oh, I'd written a book.
-So you could write.
Yeah, so you could do that.
-Your diary.
You're a big diary writer.
-Yeah, I have a diary, yeah.
-Your blog.
-It just went online.
-I'm sure when you go
shopping for groceries,
you write down a few things.
-Yes, yes, thank you.
So I felt prepared to write
a global sensation sitcom
that is now broadcast
in 130 countries. Thank you.
-130. That's amazing.
-I don't know
if there are 130 countries.
I have to look at the --
that's what they told me.
-I think it's 132.
-Wow.
-I assume there's more.
-More coming.
And then what was it like there
the first time
you sat down to collaborate?
Because obviously you liked each
other's style on social media.
But that's a different thing
when you're in a room writing.
-It was like a weird first date.
-That you had to work at.
-Yeah.
It was like a date where
you decide to break the ice
by writing a sitcom about
the difficulties of marriage.
-Deeply personal stuff.
-Yeah.
-Imagine if we knew each other
really well
and we're going through
incredible difficulty
instead of just being new pals
who just met three minutes ago.
-It was weird and awkward,
but you get over it.
I mean, it's weird writing --
or it's uncomfortable
writing comedy with someone,
anyway,
because you got to really put
yourself on the line
and be prepared
to say funny stuff
and not have anyone laugh at it.
-Yeah.
I think the other hard part
is being the person
who then has to say,
"I don't like that."
-That is also hard.
-That's not easy, either. Yeah.
-I found out that --
you had a hard time --
We used to write it when we
lived in different countries.
-When we would write remotely
and Sharon would be like,
"I'm not sure if we should do
this part," I'd be like,
"Oh, really?"
I would yell at my computer.
Because you know how e-mail
always sounds worse.
But we're in the same room.
If she was like, "What if
we did it this way?"
I'd be like,
"That's a super idea, partner."
But with e-mail, I'd throw
the laptop under the bus.
-For those who don't know,
you were on business.
You're basically an American man
on business in London,
you guys have a one-night stand,
you get pregnant.
-One-week stand.
-One-week stand. That's right.
And then you decide to --
when you get pregnant,
you decide to move to London
and have the baby.
I will say there's a lot of --
it's like a married couple
making it work.
Sounds like 80% of all sitcoms,
but yet you guys manage to avoid
most of the sitcom tropes that
I feel like people fall into.
Were there ones you were
particularly trying to avoid?
-Well, yeah.
We'd seen a lot of sitcoms
where the husband was like,
"Bam! Football!"
[ Laughter ]
And where the wife was like,
"Yeah," with the ironing thing.
You know, the ironing thing.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And so we didn't
want to do that
because we're both married
in real life
and being married
is fascinating.
It isn't boring.
It isn't, like, "Ugh."
It's like you want to kill
each other with a hammer
or you're hugging each other
around the ankles being like,
"I can't believe you love me."
And so you spend more time
at those poles
than you do in the middle.
Be like, "Buh!"
[ Laughter ]
That was not a dig at Al Bundy.
I love him.
But you know what I mean?
-Sure.
-We want to show
what it really felt like.
So that was our goal.
-Yeah.
There's basic things
we didn't want in there.
Like, we didn't want it
to be sentimental.
So we didn't really say,
"I love you."
-Yeah.
-Except for maybe one.
Out of the whole four seasons,
I think we said --
-We were allowed to show
that they loved each other
but never say.
-Yeah.
-There was no cute kids.
I mean, there's kids in it.
-And they are cute.
-They're grand.
[ Laughter ]
We didn't want to give them
any lines.
-Yeah, they're not precocious.
-We wouldn't know how to
write that, anyway.
-And there's lots of good
sitcoms already being made
where the kid's like, "I put
peanut butter in the toaster."
[ Laughter ]
And we figured that those
sitcoms are already out there.
We'll just do -- We will show
a relationship under the stress
of having kids, but we don't
need to, you know --
-And there's no --
no loving sex.
There's no nice-looking sex.
There's no sex where we
look like we're in love.
It's just like, you know --
-It's always like,
"Guess we got to do this."
-Hurried.
-Very negotiated.
-Yeah.
-I would say when my wife and I
watch it and, you know, again,
it's half an hour, we,
like, side-eye each other,
like seven times
an episode because --
-That's great.
-Yeah.
Her favorite thing that ever
happened in an episode
is I believe the dog has died.
-Yes.
-And you're upset.
And you ask,
"Are you're upset
because the dog has died?"
And you're upset because
the guests won't leave.
-Won't leave.
[ Laughter ]
-That hit my wife more
in her core than anything.
And me -- spoiler alert --
because in the upcoming season,
you eat a -- like, a yogurt
and then you get mad at him
because it's the kid's food.
-Yeah.
-And then you scream
that it's not the kid's food
because you paid for it.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not gonna lie.
That's a conversation that,
maybe not in those exact words,
but it's happened in
the Meyers family household.